Larry I'm wondering if you can tell us
the first screenplay you've ever sold
and what was happening in your life at
that time the first screenplay
I sold was Beetlejuice and I had been a
screenwriter with screenwriting I was
also working as a story analyst I was
Union story analyst local 8 5 4 I still
have my card in case all else fails and
I worked all around I mean I worked at
every studio in town and I I was working
at Paramount I was as a story analyst I
suffered a real case of writer's block
and I had a chance to audition to become
in a studio executive for Jeff
Katzenberg and Michael Eisner I saw that
as sort of a doorway out out of
screenwriting which I was feeling very
up in the air about and wondering if I
could really do it and I became a studio
secretary for a couple of years at
Paramount and then I went to work for
Walter Hill the great director Walter
Hill as his head of development and
there were a series of incidents that
made me realize that I was giving away
my best ideas and giving away my talent
in a way I was no longer comfortable
with and I wanted to go back to
screenwriting and and I formed a
partnership with the two Michaels as I
refer to them the late Michael bender
who was my producing partner and the
late Michael McDowell who was my Beatles
his writing partner and we wrote
Beetlejuice on spec and
finished it and I had taken a reduction
in salary and gone back to script
reading to support us will support
myself and my family well while we were
writing Beetlejuice and so that was the
first that that was the first one and
when it was finished I had a very good
relationship with a very prominent
studio head who shall remain nameless
and and when Beetlejuice was finished I
gave it to him to read on a Friday and
he said I'm happy to read it and I got a
call on a Monday that he wanted to meet
with me and I thought oh my gosh you
know he read it he must love it or he
would not be summoning me to his office
so quickly and I went into his office
and he said to me Larry what are you
doing he said you have actually a very
good future as an executive as a
producer this piece of crap is going to
sink you and sink your career why would
you put this on the marketplace
representing you and he said it's weird
it makes no sense it's not commercial
and I left that meeting as you can
imagine a to say to say a little taken
aback a little would be putting it
mildly he could not understand why I
would want this bizarre piece of junk
representing me and but I had also given
it to because I've taught for like 25-30
years primarily at UCLA and I was
teaching a story analysis class at that
time and I had a student named Marjorie
Lewis and I thought she was the smartest
young woman in my class and she had a
low-level
a development job at the Geffen company
and I'd given it her to her to read only
to see what she thought because I really
had learned the value of her opinion and
so coming out of this meeting feeling
very bad about myself
I called Marjorie and I said did you
read it she said yes I read it and I
said did you like it and she said like
it I'm going to get the Geffen company
to buy it and add and knowing Marjorie
what she did was that she just put it on
people's desk and she was so tenacious
and she was so annoying that people just
finally said okay we'll read it will
read it and and that's how it got to the
Geffen Company and that's how it got
read and Marjorie is a prophet like I
said probably one of two unsung heroes
of that and and and the Geffen company
proceeded to buy it for our asking price
oh my god which was incredible and and
on it went and we can talk more about
that experience as you want to do I'm
wondering the timeframe from when you
had this epiphany or this thing that
happened where you said I no longer want
to give away whatever it was your advice
or your wisdom and your talent in this
manner anymore from when you were in
more of an administrative or executive
type role yeah and one is it how what
was the timeframe from then when
Marjorie finally got it to the Geffen
company well I had uh might when I when
I went to work for Walter Hill I left
paramount I went to work for Walter Hill
and the Phoenix company and and Walter
was one of the producers of alien the
first alien film and Anna's partner and
and my my two bosses David Guyler was
another one of the producers and when I
went to work for them one of the first
things I said to me one of the primary
things that your job is going to be is
to find us a writer for the Ailey
sequel and I and without going into
detail certain promises were made to me
if I found that writer good things would
happen I will just leave it at that and
I met with Jim Cameron and that this
that this is I I I'm going to say I
discovered Jim Cameron for aliens and
that's pretty true but if you had my job
and Jim McKay and this was I believe
that Terminator was maybe in
pre-production or post-its is long
enough I don't remember but Terminator
was was not out there but if you read
the script of Terminator and met Jim
Cameron and you didn't think that he was
going to be the Jim Cameron you didn't
deserve my job so this was this was
hardly like a great insight on my part
you just met met Jim and he was a force
of nature
and you could just feel the talent but
it still was a hard sell because he had
he had a not very good movie called
piranha to that that you know that I had
to show people and this was back in the
day when you had to set up a projector
and hit an office and and hope all the
light wasn't bleeding and and but I just
but anyway that it was it was a bit of a
struggle as a bit of a fight but Jim not
only became the writer obviously but the
director of aliens and I went to my
bosses and said okay I think I did my
job I think I not only brought the
writer to the project I brought the
director to the project look what I did
and they said yes he did so what and it
was enough I just felt and I'd had an
experience at Paramount with a film
called young Sherlock Holmes which was a
regional finance ecute II there we were
under so much pressure
to bring in ideas that I did something I
told myself I was never going to do
because I sort of had a little file of
ideas that one day if I write again I'm
going to write and that was one of them
and I brought that in and there were a
lot of promises made to me if that got
made great things would happen and it
did get made a written by Chris Columbus
and I I just I just realized and also I
just I was a writer I mean that's who I
was and I'd let that go and I had
allowed myself to suffer a classic case
of writer's block and and I just said
I'm going to be a writer again and I got
I got very blessed having my partner
Michael McDowell who was as professional
a writer as I'd ever come across and
working with him it inspired me
challenged me made me understand what it
truly meant to be a writer and
screenwriter and a screen writer with a
career and I and when it went and and
the the epiphany was actually I don't
want to I want to be a writer again and
I'm just kind of selling myself short
and selling my talent short by not doing
it and get over the fear and and do it
how many hours a week were you working
before and then once you said you took
did you say you took a script reader job
and I hear down yeah I mean when I was
at Paramount we we worked seven days a
week there's stories about Jeff
Katzenberg and his work schedule that
people think are apocryphal maybe
they're not there there would never be a
job in in Hollywood that I would be
afraid of after working for Jeff he was
it because we worked seven days a week
14 16 18 hours a day and and he was a
very demanding boss but he was a great
boss and I developed an enormous amount
and have
never gone to college never had that
experience I felt like I was in the most
brilliant film school in the world
having that job and again incredibly
demanding in terms of time and and and
and just feeling like you never left the
office but it was it was a it was a boot
camp but it was a great boot camp but I
was also and and I wasn't writing then
not because I didn't have time to write
I could always have found a half hour
every day to write but I just didn't
think of myself as a writer anymore but
when I was when I finally started
writing with Michael McDowell me started
writing people too so I would do my my
day job fit it in and then Michael and I
would work I mean and you know and we'd
slide in our to a day and then we got
some financing where I could leave
behind the script reading we could focus
on beetlejuice
you